Usually, Lev Ponomaryov spends his days in
the office fighting for human rights.
He helps those who've been unjustly imprisoned
get released.
But today his desk is empty.
Ponomaryov himself has been taken into custody
and faces 25 days in prison.
The government accused him of using facebook
to incite protests supporting imprisoned activists.
In this publication, Ponomaryov supports parents
who are organising a demonstration for the
rights of their daughter who has been accused
of extremist activities against the state.
This accusation was formulated with the help
of the Russian secret service.
At least that's what Oleg Elanchik and his
colleagues think.
That's why they're here today.
The 28-year-old would have never thought,
that he'd have to help his boss get out of
prison.
Elanchik sets out to where Lev Ponomaryov
is being held.
Here he meets up with Ponomayov's lawyer.
We will file complaints.
We hope that the court will correct their
mistakes in the second appeal.
Representatives of human rights organisations
have come to the prison in a show of solidarity.
The government wants to scare activists and
all those who go to events where people fight
for human rights.
For them, the process is politically motivated.
That is why they are fighting it with political
as well as legal methods.
Many people are visiting him and bringing
him things that he needs in prison.
We are also going to the European Court to
protest his imprisonment.
They plan on doing everything they can to
help Lev Ponomarjov be freed.
One of the first reactions came from Mikhail
Fedotov.
He is the head of President Putins human rights
council.
Fedotov criticized the verdict, which he called
'inexplicable'.
Amnesty international and other human rights
organizations condemned the imprisonment of
Ponomarev as well.